former president and first lady that
would be barack and michelle obama
returned to the white house together
yesterday for the first time since they
left back in 2017. president biden and
first lady dr jill biden who were the
second couple during the obama
administration brought them back to
unveil their official portraits nancy
cordes shows us a white house
homecoming that was delayed for several
years the obamas and dozens of former
aides returned to the east room
wednesday for a tradition that dates
back to the carter era rock and michelle
welcome home
the unveiling of their official
portraits that will hang in the white
house for posterity i want to thank
sharon sprung for capturing everything i
love
about michelle
her grace
her intelligence
and the fact that she's fine
former president obama's portrait was
done by robert mccurdy who is known for
his ultra-realistic paintings that could
almost be confused for photos you'll
note that he refused to hide
any of my gray hairs
refused my request to make my ears
smaller typically a president's portrait
is unveiled during his successor's term
but president trump skipped that
tradition and then came coveted our
democracy is so much stronger than our
differences michelle obama's portrait
has been hidden away in the artist
sharon sprung's brooklyn studio for six
years a portrait of a biracial kid with
an unusual name
and the daughter of a water pump
operator and a stay-at-home mom
what we are seeing is a reminder that
there's a place for everyone in this
country this morning their portraits
have already taken their place on the
white house walls for cbs mornings i'm
nancy cordes at the white house
i think the portrait looked fantastic i
think hers in particular is stunning he
looks good too but you said they're
making jokes online yeah i mean
barack obama looks like a news anchor
yeah like a news anchor let's say promo
for a news show
and her and she looks cover of an art
magazine but he had this big idea that
presidents are not gods they are people
and that's why he wanted his portrait to
be human no i think they're both great
yeah i think they're both look fantastic